so we went from a bunch of shorts to
just to to a bunch of shorts to just to
again only this time there was a feeling
that the stories they picked were much
more out of the norm
these weren't really fairytale they were
sort of classic stories both have their
funny upbeat moments but both have this
very underlining dark tone throughout
the whole thing even the setting for the
narrators is a little off it's just this
dark dark library you don't even see the
narrator it's just these books sort of
floating in the stained glass window
with a candle in it when I was a kid I
loved it as an adult I still love it but
heck let's talk about them individually
you got the wind and the Willows which
when you get down to it is another very
strange book not that animals are
walking and talking that's not the weird
part it's the fact that everybody else
in the world is human and not just that
they're to scale the rat is literally
the size of a rat that just looks so odd
but the rest of the story seems to
follow pretty closely to the book you
got toad who's an extremist with
anything anything that's new anything
that's hot he's all over it
mania as the Brits like to call it and
he suddenly gets obsessed with motor
cars so he makes a really stupid deal
with a guy named weepy who no I'm sure
is some sort of ethnic stereotype in
that he hands over Toad Hall in exchange
for the car but in court weepy tells a
different story and says that toad stole
the car which gets in thrown in jail and
only his friends are able to save them
moley and rat are a lot of fun toad is
enjoyably crazy and even that horse gets
a few good one liners but oh maybe get a
mulligan
the only way a gentleman gets anything
the honest way and what is the honest
way ha ha I thought you wouldn't know
that government fucking love their wine
next you have the Legend of Sleepy
Hollow which in terms of story layout
even to the original book is so odd to
me but I really love it because that
most of the short is just a Chabad crane
and how he interacts with the people in
the town he has a bully he has a
girlfriend
a little bit of a love triangle and most
of it is done through mine yeah Bing
Crosby narrating it but for the most
part people don't really
Hauk and yet so much character still
comes out of them including the fact
that something I never knows as a kid if
the plot is kind of a dick I mean we
look at what he wants to do he wants to
marry this woman and mainly get her
money I mean he's already fantasizing
her father being out of the picture well
he old goat can't take it with him and
when he cuts out that's what I cut in
I think a lot of people when they look
back think of Ichabod Crane is just this
innocent that gets killed by the
Headless Horseman but no he was actually
sort of a bastard which for Disney is
kind of interesting as well the few
times where you actually have sort of a
jerk be your lead in fact you couldn't
make the argument that Brom bones though
he's a bit of a bully is much more of a
good guy I mean he doesn't do anything
really wrong or at least not as wrong as
Ichabod after all we know maybe he make
a better boyfriend who knows but of
course the part everyone remembers is
the built up appearance of the Headless
Horseman I got that laugh is cool I
think it's one of those rare times that
a lot of kids found themselves both
scared and laughing at the same time the
climax is a lot of fun that way it's
sort of like Evil Dead 2 in fact I'd be
shocked if director Sam Raimi didn't
take a lot of the atmosphere and tone
directly from this cartoon
yeah it's just your classic ghost story
with a classic ghost story ending and
the two seem to go actually pretty well
together
let's take advantage of the fact that
cinematic and they can get a lot of fun
angles and they also stick true to their
stories as well as taking some creative
liberties
whenever anyone thinks wind in the
willow or Sleepy Hollow these are
usually the first two versions that come
in mind and that's probably not so bad
it's good to read the originals of
course but these are pretty good
adaptations it's heavy on the dark but
also big on the last either one is great
on its own but back-to-back they work
just as good you can't read
man I'm getting out of here